محمد بن سلمان
التي قام بها الغزاه الروس ليس صواريخها
كحاله الروسي لدينا قوه جويه اقل
ولا نمتلك
وفرتها ايران لروسيا وليس لدينا الكثير من
المدفعيه ولكننا راسخ القدم اقوياء لان
الحقه بجانبنا
وبالاضافه الى ذلك نحن ندحر الغزاه بعيدا
عن ارضنا
يدافع عن ارضه ضد الغازاته ويدافع عن
اطفاله
ضد العبوديه
كل محارب من هذا القبيل
الحق بجانبه والعداله بجانبه وانا امثل
هؤلاء المقاتلين وامثل الشعب الاوكراني
باسره ان
الاوكرانيون لم يختاروا الحرب
قوتنا لم تنطلق الى اراضي الغير ونحن لا
ننهك في ضم ونهب لموارد اي دوله اخرى
ولكننا لن نستسلم
ولن نخضع لاي محتل او اي اجنبي لذلك
نقاتله وانا
متاكد بان اممكم تفهم هذه المشاعر وانا
متاكد انكم تفهموا
بما نقوم به ونداء لكم هو ان تحموا
شعبنا بما في ذلك الجاليه الاوكرانيه
المسلمه ومعي هنا
الموقر مصطفى الجميل وهو زعيم تتاري القرم
وهو احد الاشخاص
الاوكرانيين
ووطنه القرم مركز
المسلمين القرن
لقرون تتاروا القرم كانوا وينبغي ان
يكونوا جزءا لا يتجزا من الامه الاسلاميه
ولكن القربه يعاني من الاحتلال الروسي
ولغايه الان اولئك الذين يخضعون للقمع في
شبه القرم المحتله هم من المسلمين ولدينا
تجربه ايجابيه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه فيما يخص اطلاق سراحه بعض اولئك
الذين اعتقلوا بالروس ويمكننا ان نوسع من
حلقه هذه التجربه حتى
الرغم وجودي اختلاف
من قبل بعض الدول لكننا يمكن ان يكون
موحدين
لانقاذ الناس من السجون الروسيه وللسوء
الحظ هنالك البعض وبعضكم ايضا
اخفل تلك السجون واخفف الضمه غير القانوني
لذلك انا موجود هنا بشحمه ولحمه لكي ننظر
الى المساله بغض النظر عن نفوذ الروس
وجهودهم يجب علي ان اشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واشكر السواد الاعظم منكم
لدعم
موقفنا هو ميثاق الامم المتحده ايها
المقرون لقد شهدتم بان الاوكران هم شعب
يحب السلام في عام
2021 ان
التزمنا بالانفتاح وقد مدينا مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وعمان والمراه المتحده
والبحرين والكويت وانتم تعرفون اوكرانيا
وانا سعيد بان سواحكم
اتوا الى
عاصمتنا وراوا بهاء جبال الكربون حدود
الامل في يوم من الايام
لهؤلاء ان يعودوا لكي يروا شبه القرم حره
من
الغزو الروسي والاحتلال الروسي وهنالك
ايضا روابط تعليميه عشره الالاف من الطلاب
العرب يدرسون في جامعتنا في كل سنه
وبطبيعه الحال هذا يشرفنا من المغرب ومصر
والاردن والعراق ولبنان والجزائر والليبيا
وتونس
طلاب بالفعل يدرسون في الجامعه الاوكرانيه
وقد وفينا باهم مهمه في عالمنا معكم الامن
الغذائي اوكرانيا توفر لدوالكم القمح
وايضا منتجات زراعيه اخرى ونحن
نرحب
باستثمار الدول العربيه واستثمر قطر في
بناء
الموارد ابانا الجائحه
ايضا سعار العدوان قد اثر على علاقاتنا
ولكن انا متاكد
بانه ما من احد منكم
يوافقوا على التخلي عن جزء من اراضيكم لاي
غاز وانا متاكد انه ما من احد منكم سوف
يشاهدوا سرقه اجنبي لاطفالكم مئه الالاف
من اطفالنا رحلوا الى روسيا وان فصلوا عن
اهاليهم
والرسل يحاولون الان ان يعلموا اطفالنا
بان يكرهوا من هم من بني جلدتهم وانا
متاكد انه ما من احد منكم سوف يعترفوا
بالاحتلاء احتلال محطه طاقه نوويه
انظروا الى العذابات التي تادت عن الحروب
في اليمن وسوريا وفي بلدان اخرى
سيما السودان والصومال وفي العراق
وافغانستان
هذه عذابه تضاف الى عذابات اخرى بسبب
العدوان وكل شخص يريد العداء ويريد ان
نعود الى ايام الغزو
وكل عدو يريد فعل ذلك سوف يتكبد تكلفه
باهظه وانا ارحب بكم جميعا
لانضمامكم الى مسار العداله لدينا صيغه
اوكرانيا للسلام لكي ننهي الحرب
وهنالك مثال ايجابي الا وهو الامن الغذائي
حتى ابانا الحرب نحن نقوم بكل باب وسعنا
لكي تكون منازل الجميع تحصل على الغذاء
وهنالك كما تعرفون صفقه البحر الاسود
للحبوب
ورفعنا جزئيا حصار روسيا على موانئنا وهذا
يحل يحل الاستقرار في سوق الحبوب سيما في
الكثير من الدول العربيه ان تطبيق
صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه سوف تساعد
الكثيرين وسوف يساعد ذلك على تحرير
السجناء والمرح وعوده المرحلين كل وفد
موقر وفر له وفر له وثيقه بعشر نقاط
تعكس صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه يمكنكم ان
تستانسوا بها ويمكن ان تقراونها وانا
ساكون ممتن لكم اذا ما اخترتم مسار انقاذ
ارواح الناس
والسجناء
الذين
تمسك بهم الروسيه احييكم واشجعكم على تبني
واقرار هذه الصيغه لك ننحي العذابات جانبا
روسيا الدوله
المعتديه وعدوانها لا يتاتى من القوه
ولكنه يتاتى
يجب ان يتاتى من معادله المفادها ان ايام
العدوانيه يجب ان تذهب ادراج الرياح وهذا
ما برهنته اوكرانيا اتمنى لكم السلامه
وادعوكم للتعاون مباشره مع بلدنا من دون
اي وسيط
دعونا نعمل على نحو منسق من اجل السلام
ومن اجل خير جميع الامم وارجو ان تصغوا
الى مسلمي القرمه ومسلمي اوكرانيا
فليحمي الله
جنودنا والمجد لاوكرانيا شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]